all right totally different format for
the show today things are a little mixed
up backwards upside down because of the
Columbus Day weekend and holiday so
we're actually gonna go right to the
phones today at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty let's jump
right into calls with our first caller
from the 269 area code let's see what's
on people's minds a lot of news this
week a caller from 269
what's your name and what's on your mind
today my name is Braden Braden Kibby
from Kalamazoo great what can we do for
you today hey I was just wondering I
wanted your opinion on the federal
prohibition of marijuana and maybe what
you think the timeline on that changing
is timeline is tough I mean if I'm
against it I'm against it I think that
at the top of the list in terms of
really making progress on marijuana
legalization and decriminalization we've
got to get marijuana cannabis
rescheduled out of being scheduled one
at the federal level how it's going to
happen I don't know I mean there I've
done quite a bit of reading about this
there's one perspective which is when we
see some critical mass of states
decriminalize and/or legalize then the
federal government will take it more
seriously but there are people who don't
agree with that who say this is not like
gay marriage in any way and that that's
not going to happen so I couldn't tell
you I mean I would love to say within
five years something would happen
federally on marijuana but I don't know
braid now I'm not super optimistic yeah
it's a rough life with the current
Attorney General I guess oh yeah big big
anti-pot guy KKK wasn't bad until he
found out that they were smoking pot and
then all of a sudden I guess now that
then it was a bad organization in his
mind you know oh yeah yep alright Braden
thanks very much appreciate the call
that was a very specific question I like
that one right right to the point okay
taking the balls thanks Braden
appreciate it